[Music]
shaming
sure the song is great and it's fun to
see all our springfield pals but this
full intro is over a minute long and i
don't care if you're one of the greatest
shows of all time if you use more than a
minute on your opening theme you're
getting a sin
letting a baby ride in the front seat
including princess cashmere aka april
flowers aka shauna tifton in this
opening couch gag
instead of carl carlson whose name i
feel compelled to point out for no
reason whatsoever is not grogu groguson
also shortly after this everyone in this
room tested positive for coronavirus and
only nelson and a poo lived
and you thought 2021 was going to get
better
[Music]
show has the audacity to double opening
themis
homer survives this or at least comes
away with no injuries
he's about to hit a chestnut tree
[Laughter]
smithers is okay standing in some
leftover toxic waste and while i can't
find definitive proof that it would have
any lasting adverse effects i have seen
friday the 13th part 8 jason takes
manhattan
twice where should we dump this batch
the playground
no all those bold children are arousing
suspicion
simpsons gives us the charlie brown
origin story without having the decency
to do a cutaway parody and family guy
that joke right into our face
and yes this is a sent on family guy in
a simpsons episode you knew who we were
when you clicked
arbor octopuses and yes i know you think
it should be arbor octopi but
you are wrong also if the tree with nine
drums of toxic waste has turned this
tree into a half octopus then
shouldn't the acorns growing on it be
different too some boy scouts stumbled
on your little game of hide the ooze
title of my sex tape at this point let's
just go with some
having a character in the 90s dress up
as hannibal lecter in a comedic
situation cliche
smithers my wallet's in my right front
pocket
if they've arrested or committed him how
does he still have his wallet that's one
of the first things they confiscate
also i'm not buying that three million
dollars cash would even fit into a
wallet even if it work it stands a
wallet
oh handicap you wife beating drunk
says the child strangling also drunk and
maybe that's the point but
we don't stand for things that poke fun
at stuff as a way to poke fun at
themselves around here
it's just so lazy how is bart
controlling five separate ants with a
single controller
and before you say it's his daydream
dummy i already thought of that and
decided i didn't care
the real question here is why they're
stealing those microwaves when there are
probably tvs in there
pardon me but i would like to see this
money spent on more police officers
the sapoo request has aged poorly in so
many different ways that it might be the
scene that is aged the poorest in all of
our tv sense videos and we've covered
the original twilight zone and star trek
series
chat away i'll just amuse myself with
some pornographic playing cards
remember when the idea of a politician
saying something like this in public was
ridiculous and only used in satirical
situations
we could put all our eggs in one basket
not understanding sarcasm also known as
twitter you know a town with money is a
little like the mule with a spinning
wheel
man i miss phil hartman there are a lot
of things that make this one of the
greatest episodes on one of the greatest
shows ever he's towed the top of that
list here's a few sends off for one of
the greats gone too
soon the name's lanley lyle lanley
episode leaves me wondering how lyle
knew springfield had all this money a
local business person paying a fine even
an excessive one wouldn't make the
national news homer read the story in a
free local newspaper was lyle just
randomly passing through springfield
because he doesn't strike me as the type
of person that would be spending time
anywhere unless it benefited him
also why is there piano on this stage
not on your life my hindu friend
assuming you know someone's religion by
their race i guess what i mean to say is
that's racist
can superman outrun the flash uh sure
why not
dc's entire approach to the dc eu
somehow makes it into the script
i don't know whether they eat you or
kiss you
celebrity voice impersonated the funny
thing is 1993 marlon brando would have
zero qualms about being part of
truckasaurus are you on your third beer
of the evening
does whiskey count his beer that's
hilarious but homer is clearly drinking
beer
so then mono means one and
rail means rail so it's just another
word for monogamy then
got it after an exhaustive search
springfield has found its monorail
conductor
the most confusing aspect of this
episode might be that the monorail only
has one conductor
i don't know why i leave this lying
around trying to forgive your own
convenience sins by making fun of them
yourself
denied ah sudden discount keith richards
are we just gonna ignore that brockman
has a mini-me
what is little brockty's story and why
are we focused on that he's cool
he's sexy he's 34 years old jeez how old
do you guys think 34
is i'd say this vessel could do at least
warp five
and let me say may the force be with you
mistaking doctor who for battlestar
galactica but they would have tested the
monorail
right even with lanley cutting corners
someone still would have driven it
around a few times to make sure it was
working so how would laney even be able
to make sure nothing went wrong before
he left town
but why would you put a picture of the
hindenburg on the wall it's not like
it's
less expensive than other pictures isn't
the whole point that he cuts cost
wherever he could i swear it's like it's
just there for some sort of joke
you see the doors on star trek were not
mechanical we had a stage hand on either
side who would pull the door open when
he saw you approach
overthinking tv shows wait our non-stop
flight to tahiti will be making a brief
layover in north haverbrook
if north haverbrook has an operating
airport then why did the town look so
run down when marge was there an airport
would mean lots of jobs right
[Music]
this works these people have plenty of
time to not only see that the escalator
ends but also that the people in front
of them are dropping let
the filibustering begin
[Music]
tired
what do they do with these things after
we seal them the sewer floods out with
the stuff every night at midnight
there's someone out there again isn't
there
a bad boy with pastries hello
lisa i'm genghis khan you'll go where i
go
defile what i defile eat who i eat
you want a twinkie just call off your
giant mechanical ants
do you want ants because that's how you
get ants get to the money
get to the money to the monster
help you cultivate horse sense and a
cool head and a keen
eye yes mr lowry
lion still isn't in no mr larry but then
she's always a bit late on monday
mornings
stick your head out the window boy it's
the greatest